und es hat sich
ausgeleiert ja leider es gibt
Riesenwirbel um den Sommerhit Layla erst
riesen Diskussion ob DJ Robin und
schütze ihren Hits beim ZDF
Fernsehgarten performen dürfen Sie
diesen Jubel danach aber diesen Zopf
Beschwerden klagen und jetzt die
Konsequenz ja Layla darf nicht zur ZDF
Silvestershow die heißt doch so nett
willkommen 2023 aber ohne Layla neun
Wochen lang großer großer Nummer 1
Hitler
hören Sie Layla überall in Deutschland
nur nicht im ZDF in dem Abend ja also
eine ganz bewusste senderentscheidung
offenbar an dem Abend gegen das zweite
Layla überall anders nur an dem Abend
[Applaus]
[Musik]